Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 68. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove, hallo, ich begrüße euch und ich bin immer noch on Tour. Dieses Mal bin ich in Bonn gelandet und ich bin hier im schönen Netzladen, ein weiterer Hacker Space, der hier auch immer mal wieder in verschiedenen Sendungen erwähnt worden ist. Jetzt bin ich live vor Ort. 19. Januar 2008 und zu Gast ist Daniel Molkentin, den ich mir jetzt mal rausgepickt habe. Ein sehr kurzfristig anbraunter Podcast, denn es gibt auch einen guten Anlass und den will ich nicht ungenutzt lassen, denn heute wird hier Abend im Netzladen eine Party stattfinden. Das ist nicht der eigentliche Grund für diesen Podcast, aber der Anlass für die Party ist der Grund. Wir werden hier die KDE4 Release Party feiern, das K Desktop Environment war hier bei KDE4 schon vor einem Jahr oder so schon mal Thema, wo wir diesen Ausblick auf die neue Version auch schon mal geleistet haben. Jetzt ist es endlich so weit und ja, du Daniel, du bist ja Teil des Entwicklungsteams von KDE schon ziemlich lange. Seit wann bist du dabei?
Etwas seit 2000.
2000, also schon gut sieben Jahre. Das ist ja schon einiges und da ging das ja auch erst los, oder?
Nein, das erste Release ist 1998 und gegründet. Wir haben ja kürzlich Zehnjähriges gefeiert, letztes Jahr 26.
Okay, ich habe eine Party verpasst.
Genau, Stuttgart, das war großer Terror.
Okay, aber das ist trotzdem relativ früh dazu gestoßen, kann man schon sagen. Was sind so deine Interessensfelder und wo hast du dich damit eingebracht?
Ja, ursprünglich war es halt das Übliche. Mich hat etwas gestört, ich habe einen Patch geschickt. Das war damals in der JavaScript-Bibliothek von Khtml, womit wir alle unter KDE im Web surfen. Ja, und später hat sich das so ein bisschen verlagert hin zu Personal Information Management und Groupware. Ich habe dann mit ein paar anderen Leuten zusammen Kontakt maintained.
Kontakt ist dieses Adressbuch-Subsystem von KDE?
Nein, Kontakt ist das, was bestehende Anwendungen so zusammenfasst, dass es hinterher ausschaut, wie, ich sage jetzt mal ganz böse Outlook, weil viele Leute das halt so gewohnt sind und es eigentlich auch nicht das beste, aber auch nicht das verkehrteste System ist, um zu arbeiten.
Es fasst Programme zusammen, damit es so aussehen wie Outlook. Was heißt das genau?
Genau, das heißt, wir hatten also vorher schon K-Mail, K-Organizer, K-Mail.
Ach K-Mail, also das Mail-Programm, okay.
Genau.
K-Mail.
Das ist der Hammerwitz und du bist nicht der erste.
Das glaube ich sofort, aber ich bin selber draufgekommen.
Danke. Na, und da gibt es halt noch ein paar andere Sachen, die wir im sogenannten Personal Information Management Modul dran hatten, zum Beispiel Syncing, was mittlerweile auf dem Open Sync Projekt basiert, wo wir also sehr viel Energie haben, weil wir uns einfach nicht mehr um das eigentliche Sünden kümmern müssen. Und das vereinigt das im Prinzip so unter einer Haube, so dass man halt Daten hin und her schieben kann zwischen diesen einzelnen Modulen. Und wer halt sagt, das ist mir alles zu viel, und auch, look, war mir eh schon immer so spekt, der benutzt die Programme halt weiterhin parallel und verliert dadurch eigentlich auch nichts. Also ich denke, das war eine recht gute Lösung, die wir da gefunden haben für KDE3 jetzt.
Das ist ja auch schon so eine Stoßrichtung von KDE immer gewesen, sozusagen dem Windows Desktop eine Alternative entgegenzuerhalten. Das kam auch, wenn ich das mal so unterstellen darf, auch so im Look and Feel am Anfang eigentlich auch sehr deutlich zur Sprache. Man hat da sehr viele Zitate bemüht aus der Windows-Welt. Das ist aber jetzt nicht mehr so sehr der Fokus, oder? Ich habe so den Eindruck gewonnen, dass man eigentlich jetzt eher so seine eigene Designlinie gefunden hat oder zumindest finden möchte.
Ja, das ist definitiv so. Auf der einen Seite müssen wir natürlich den Benutzer schon noch da abholen, wo er herkommt. Auf der anderen Seite kann es ja nicht immer nur Ziel der Sache sein, immer der Microsoft-Welt hinterherzulaufen. Genau das tut man ja. Also immer wenn ich irgendwas kopiere, laufe ich hinterher. Und nur wenn ich irgendwie so eine Mischung zwischen kopieren und selber entwickeln und neue Ideen finde, kann ich wirklich eine brauchbare Alternative sein.
Das KDE-Projekt ist ja auch als dieser sehr stark in Deutschland verwurzelten Projekte.
Ja, wurde in Tübingen gegründet.
Dem ist auch wahrscheinlich immer noch so. Also es hat hier einfach seine stärkste Unterstützung. Ist das hier, unterstelle ich jetzt mal, ist das noch so richtig oder hat sich das mittlerweile nivelliert?
Es hat sich, also wenn man sich mal so die Accounts anguckt, wo kommen die her? Also wir haben auch so eine Map auf der KDE-Seite, wo man sich angucken kann, wo kommen die Leute her? Dann werden die Punkte in den USA immer mehr und auch so in Europa breitet sich das so, wenn man so eine Pockeninfektion in Deutschland und es breitet sich dann so, wenn man es zeitlich sieht, immer mehr so über Europa aus. Also es ist nicht mehr so, dass wenn jetzt jemand die Bombe auf Deutschland schmeißt, dass KDE dann weg wäre.
Okay, da haben wir ja nochmal Glück gehabt. Und das heißt dann aber auch, dass KDE in den USA eine größere Akzeptanz gefunden hat. Weil es war ja am Anfang so, also am Anfang meine ich jetzt so die Zeit, als man sich noch nicht so richtig im Klaren war, ob es jetzt das G oder das K ist, man auch diese Entscheidung steht im Prinzip noch aus. Aber es war ganz klar zu sehen, so der amerikanische Kontinent hat sich eigentlich von vornherein sehr viel mehr der Gnomen-Welt entgegen geneigt, während hier in Europa das K stärker im Vordergrund war. Stimmt der Eindruck? Also es war zumindest so, dass die großen Distributionen in den USA sehr viel eher in Richtung Gnomen gingen und hier Suze und so weiter eben sehr viel mehr KDE unterstützt haben. So und Maxi auch dadurch neviliert haben, dass jetzt Ubuntu dann sozusagen von unten, von der Unterseite des Planetens nach oben kam und dann versucht hat, beide auch halbwegs gleich behandelt nach vorne zu bringen. Weiß ich nicht, aber wie auch immer, das ist jetzt nicht mehr so eine einfache Geschichte. Wie siehst du die Verbreitungsstand von KDE bei den Distributionen?
Na ja, wir haben ja, was so die Community-Distributionen angeht, sind wir ja ganz gut aufgestellt. Wir haben Mandriva, die ja immer noch fast komplett KDE-basiert sind. Ubuntu hast du gerade genannt, Kubuntu hast du halt beide Möglichkeiten. Bei ObenSusa hast du beide Möglichkeiten. Fedora, die ja sehr lange nur oder so einen Stiefmutter-KDE ausgeliefert haben, die machen jetzt einen KDE-Spin. Also da sehe ich das ganz gut, das ist wieder recht gut aufgestellt in den letzten Jahren.
Jetzt ist KDE Version 4 released worden, vor ein paar Tagen.
Vor genau einer Woche.
Vor genau einer Woche, genau. Und was hat es denn nun geschafft in das neue Release? Also was sind denn so die Highlights, ohne jetzt zu sehr ins Detail gehen zu wollen, aber was sind so die wichtigen Schritte, die da genommen wurden, die jetzt die neue Version ausmachen? Vielleicht kannst du das ja mal kurz anreißen.
Ja, also wenn du erst mal draufguckst, dann wird dir natürlich auffallen, es sieht alles ganz anders aus. Wir haben neue Icons, neue Design-Elemente. Das Ganze läuft dann unter dem schönen Namen Oxygen. Dann hast du den Desktop, der sieht ganz anders aus. Das Panel, das hat jetzt ein sehr viel modulares Konzept. Das läuft unter dem Stichwort Plasma. Was ist das mit dem Panel? Das ist das, wo du das Menü aufrufst, wo die Programme drinnen liegen, die du gerade gestartet hast. Wie heißt das unter Mac OS? Die Startleiste unter Windows. Das Doc. Genau, das entspricht ihm wahrscheinlich noch.
So ein Launcherelement, wo man startet.
Genau, das ist jetzt alles so in Plasma rein. Da können wir später noch mal ein bisschen genauer reingehen. Dann hast du halt sehr viele Sachen, die dir im ersten Moment verborgen bleiben.
Gibt es nicht auch so eine Entkopplung des Browsers und des Defiler-Umgebung?
Stimmt, da wäre ich jetzt fast wieder drüber gestolpert. Dolphin hast du jetzt als dedizierten File Manager. Das geht so ein bisschen mehr in die Richtung der Leute, die gesagt haben, ja, Conqueror, flexibel. Man kann damit alles angucken, alles browseren, aber da fehlt mir so ein bisschen das Paradigma dahinter. Das ist mir zu kompliziert als Einsteiger. Ich möchte das ganz einfach haben.
Vielleicht mal so ein Blick nach hinten für die Leute, die das auch nicht kennen. Ich habe selber nicht so viel genutzt, aber mein Verständnis war, man benutzt halt Conqueror und Conqueror ist sowohl ein Web-Browser als auch eben ein Blick auf das eigene Datalsystem.
Es ging sogar noch weiter. Du konntest im Prinzip alles, was du mit einer URL beschreiben konntest, konntest du im Conqueror angucken. Das war das Prinzip. Und was halt nicht ging, konntest du über sogenannte IOS-Slaves und von der Programmseite über sogenannte Parts, das sind so eine leichtgewichtige Komponentenstruktur, konntest du das halt erweitern.
Aber das hat nicht so richtig gegriffen, dass das jetzt umgestellt wurde?
Nee, das ist ja alles durchaus noch vorhanden. Also wir benutzen die Parts ja weiterhin in KDE4. Nur diese Idee, dass halt alles in einem Programm ist, das wurde von vielen ein bisschen als zu much gesehen. Die wollten es halt gerne in verschiedenen, wirklich wieder eine Aufgabe pro Programm. Also diese Unix-Philosophie. Und da geht es halt wieder ein bisschen mehr. Das ist so mein Eindruck auch, dass es in der Community verbreitet ist, wieder hin. Ohne natürlich diese Modulität zu verlieren, die du durch diese Parts hast. Das heißt, ich kann bei Bedarf mir halt diese Hilfe von den Parts, zeig mal meinen PDF an oder so.
Okay, also das greift auch in der Oberfläche, aber die Oberflächen sind erstmal getrennt. Man hat so das Web und so. Und man hat so wie auch, sagen wir mal, sowohl bei Windows als auch bei Mac, Safari Finder und Internet Explorer. Und wie heißt der Finder nochmal? Windows Explorer, keine Ahnung. Wie auch immer. Da, wo man halt irgendwie die Plusse aufmacht.
Genau, die einzige Sache ist halt, viele Leute haben gesagt, um Gottes Willen, ich werde ohne meinen Conqueror All in One nicht mehr leben können. Die können sich weiterhin sagen, okay, ich möchte File Management weiterhin im Conqueror machen. Das ist also umschaltbar.
Wie immer gibt es da so ein starkes Set an Optionen, die man sich dazuklicken kann.
Genau.
Das heißt, es geht auch so ein bisschen um eine verbesserte Benutzerfreundlichkeit, kann man das sagen? Spielt das eine große Rolle? Ich hatte ja hier vor ein paar Tagen im Chaosradio Express 64 mit Ellen Reitmayer von Usability gesprochen, die auch erzählt hat, dass mit KDE diese Usability-Aktivität begann und versucht wurde, schwerpunktmäßig bei KDE4 Einfluss zu nehmen, insbesondere bei dem Okular-Programm, diesem Führer.
Der ist auch sehr gut geworden. Ich habe ihn kürzlich erst wieder ein bisschen unter die Lupe genommen. Das war ja früher nur so ein ganz einfacher PDF-Betrachter. Obwohl er jetzt wesentlich mehr kann, ist das eigentlich ziemlich gut durchdacht.
Also diese Usability-Einschläge, die Fruchten?
Ja, also würde ich schon sagen, man kann halt nicht genug davon haben. Allen ist halt auch nur eine Person. Und obwohl das Open-Usability ganz gut vorankommt, ist KDE halt eine riesen Code-Basis, die man nicht mal eben mit ein paar Leuten und ein paar gute Ideen erschlagen kann, was natürlich wichtig war.
Aber es gibt jetzt eine Offenheit.
Es gibt eine Offenheit, und das ist halt das, was so in den letzten Jahren um sich gegriffen hat, dann auch im KDE-Projekt zu sagen, der Mensch, der hat das nicht nur studiert, sondern der hat da auch praktische Erfahrungen mitgemacht und der weiß, wie man die Leute so ausreicht, dass man rauskriegt, was sie gerne hätten. Und wenn der sagt, das ist so, dann ist da vielleicht was dran.
Heißt das, dass das auch so sich bei den Programmierern vielleicht langsam der Gedanke durchsetzt, dass man doch eher vom Benutzer zum System als vom System zum Benutzer schreiten muss?
Das sagst du jetzt jetzt zynisch. Aber es ist halt wirklich das Problem gerade von Open-Source-Software, dass du auf der einen Seite natürlich immer dieses Bedürfnis hast, ich mache damit, weil ich selber meine Probleme lösen will. Und auf der anderen Seite sagst du natürlich, naja, aber andere sollen es halt auch benutzen. Und der Königweg ist eigentlich zu sagen, okay, wie bringe ich das, was ich will und das, was nach Usability studieren oder nach dem, was ich irgendwie kriege, die anderen wollen unter einen Hut. Und das zweite große Problem ist, man hat ja eine Stichworte hier, Web 2.0, Blogs und sonst irgendwas, zu jedem, was man postet, also wenn ich jetzt als Entwickler eine Idee habe, kommt irgendwie riesen Feedback. Nur das ist natürlich immer wieder dasselbe Publikum. Das sind die Fanboys, bis die wirklich seriös begeisterten. Und das muss man sich natürlich auch bewusst sein, dass das auch nur eine sehr beschränkte Zielgruppe ist. Und da wirklich über diesen Tellerrand hinaus zu gucken, das ist halt die wirkliche Herausforderung.
Das denke ich auch. Aber auf jeden Fall, es steht schon im Mittelpunkt, das merkt man. Also es geht auch wirklich darum, ein User-Interface zu machen und zu schaffen, was hohenden Ansprüchen genügt. Ich meine, es gibt ja Konkurrenz genug. Apple schreitet derzeit doch mit hohen Speed voran.
Ich möchte von Epidemien sprechen.
Epidemien? Ja, also auf dem Kongress gab es 35% Max.
Es greift auch in die FH um sich, also es ist unglaublich.
Was hältst du davon?
Also es ist zum einen natürlich erstmal nicht verkehrt, weil man Apple, da bin ich auch ganz ehrlich, man muss den Hutz vor diesen Leuten ziehen. Auf der anderen Seite sehe ich bei Apple eben immer das Problem, das siehst du halt, wo es ganz stark um Marktinteressen geht, Richtung Medienverkauf von Content. Da sind sie ja sehr restriktiv und auch in ihren News-Aktivitäten, Stichwort jetzt hier Keynotes von Herrn Jobs und so weiter. Und es steht halt zu befürchten, dass sie mit zunehmender Marktmacht eben auch in anderen Bereichen versuchen werden, da ein bisschen eine härtere Politik zu fahren. Und das Problem, das ich so ein bisschen sehe, das man treibt, wenn man jetzt Microsoft durch Apple austauscht, so ein bisschen Teufel mit dem Bälzebub aus. Wobei man halt sagen muss, der Bälzebub fühlt sich besser an und sieht besser aus.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Na gut, man kann Apple auf jeden Fall zugutehalten, dass sie doch ein sehr viel entspannteres Verhältnis zu Open Source haben.
Das ist auf alle Fälle.
Es ist schließlich auch ein Betriebsthema, das integriert. Auf der anderen Seite ist ja nun auch KDE ein System, was auf einer Technologie basiert, die ich jetzt mal ansprechen möchte, weil ich weiß, dass du auch relativ viel darüber weißt. Hast du ein Buch darüber geschrieben, wenn ich es richtig sehe, oder zwei sogar?
Ja, eins auf Deutsch und dann hat es freundlicherweise jemand auf Englisch übersetzt.
Ach so, also ein Buch über QT4, oder wie sagt man so schön, Qt, weil es so süß ist. QT ist integraler Bestandteil von KDE. Das ist die Grundlage. Vielleicht kannst du mal kurz beschreiben, was die Aufgabe und das Wesen von QT ist. Was ist das und was macht das?
Okay, also ohne QT müssten wir halt wirklich auf ein Betriebssystem, auf den Bibliotheken aufsetzen. Wir haben uns also für C++ als Programmiersprache entschieden. Da war ja auch letztens eine Sendung bei euch drüber. Und dann ist die Frage, C++ ist eine Programmiersprache und wie komme ich jetzt weiter? Du müsstest deine komplette GUI neu programmieren. Es gab vor allen Dingen zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt, als KDE entstand, nicht wirklich Netzwerkklassen dafür, es sei denn, du greifst wirklich auf diese 10 Netzwerkklassen hinüber. Gewisse Paradigmen wie Netzwerktransparenz oder so waren eigentlich fast nicht vorstellbar.
Das heißt, QT ist ein Entwickler, Framework, Toolkit, was auch immer man es nennen möchte. Ein Set von grundlegenden Routinen, die an sich keine fertige Funktionalität bieten, aber die es einem erlauben, darauf eine aufzubauen.
Genau, du kannst dir eine komplette Applikation damit schreiben und eben nicht nur die GUI schön zusammenklicken, sondern das bringt eben auch Funktionalitäten wie Netzwerk, wie XML-Verarbeitung und so weiter mit.
Also so wichtige Dienstleistungen, die man eigentlich als Programm gerne hätte vom Betriebssystem. Das heißt, es erweitert im Falle von Linux diesen relativ nackten Körner, der sich ja eigentlich nur um eine wirkliche Kernfunktionalität kümmert, das übliche Dateisystem, Speicher und so weiter, um wirkliche richtige Services. Ich möchte Daten lesen, ich möchte Daten schreiben und so weiter. Copy-Paste, so eine Sachen sind da alles mit drin, richtig?
Genau, und es abstrahiert mich natürlich vom Betriebssystem. Also gerade im Falle von Qt ist es halt so, Qt wurde damals eigentlich geschrieben für die Pro-RC++-Programmierer, die halt Anwendungen sowohl unter den alten Unix-Boliden, als auch unter dem damals aufstrebenden Windows gerade so NT oder so laufen lassen wollten, um denen halt so ein Cross-Platform-Toolkit zu bieten. Und das hat sich dann jetzt mit Mac OS erweitert da drauf. Mittlerweile gibt es halt auch für Embedded-Devices, jetzt neuerdings sogar für Windows-CE-basierte Devices. Wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es das auch irgendwann mal für andere Betriebssysteme.
Das heißt, das Versprechen von, muss ich jetzt eigentlich Qt sagen? Oder darf ich auch QT sagen?
Sag doch Qt, das rutscht eigentlich besser runter.
Okay, dann sag ich halt Qt. It's so Qt, it's so Qt. Was hab ich gesagt? Achso, ja, das Versprechen ist, dass man im Prinzip eine Anwendung schreibt und die auf verschiedenen Plattformen zum Laufen bekommen kann. Das ist natürlich eine Heilsversprechung, die verschiedenste Systeme schon mit sich gebracht haben. Ich höre Java. Wie weit geht das? Und wie weit ist das auch wünschenswert? Wie weit hilft euch das, KDE auch unter anderem Betriebssystemen zum Laufen zu bringen?
Na, es ist halt ein Stück weit ehrlicher als Java, weil Java sagt dem Benutzer, das ist Betriebssystemunabhängig. Bei Java gibt es nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder es stimmt und es ist auf keinem System wirklich zu Hause. Gerade was GUI angeht, ich rede immer so böse. Es interessiert sich meistens auf GUI-Lösungen, weil das andere funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Oder du musst halt doch sehr viel Spezifisches immer nachregeln, sodass du letztendlich doch immer ein Windows-Binary, ein Linux-Binary und ein Mac OS-Binary dir ziehen musst für Java-Programme. Bei Qt ist es so, das ist eine ganz klare Ansage, wir liefern dir eine möglichst große Abstraktion. Wir liefern dir da, wo es notwendig ist, auch Spezialfunktionen für das jeweilige unterliegende System. Du erreichst damit einen sehr hohen Grad an Abstraktion. Wir nehmen dir genau das, das und das ab. Und um den Rest musst du dich halt kümmern. Ich würde fast sagen, ein Stück mehr Ehrlichkeit, weil man als Programmierer relativ genau weiß, woran man ist. Man muss sich halt darauf einlassen. Und gerade bei C++ ist es natürlich wesentlich systemnäher als Java.
Qt hat ja begonnen als, war im Prinzip eine proprietäre Entwicklung am Anfang von der Firma Trolltech. Ich habe das dann nur so am Rande verfolgt, aber es gab dann auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Wirbel deswegen. Das war, glaube ich, auch einer der Gründe, warum sich die Gnome-Geschichte überhaupt gestartet hat. Weil man halt gesagt hat, das ist halt jetzt nicht wirklich freies Software. Und wenn wir hier ein OS entwickeln wollen für freies Software, dann geht das nicht so. Und in der Folge wurde dann eben später Qt auch unter GPL, mittlerweile, glaube ich, released.
Genau, es ist auf allen Systemen mit, lass mich lügen, fast allen Modulen. Also ich glaube, es gibt nur noch Sachen, die dann selber irgendwelche Implikationen hätten, dass sie nicht mit GPL-Sachen gelingt werden dürfen. Die sind da nicht dabei, also von Drittherstellern. Aber sonst ist eigentlich auf allen Betriebssystemen Mac war die letzte Plattform, wo nicht alles dabei war, wo nicht alles GPL war. Egal, wo du programmierst, hast du GPL-isiertes Qt.
Und warum hat das jetzt die KDE-Entwickler am Anfang nicht gestört?
Na, weil Qt damals unter einer Lizenz stand, die schon relativ liberal war. Sie entsprach halt nicht den Guidelines von der Free Software Foundation. Aber gerade die Gründer waren da sehr pragmatisch unterwegs. Sie haben gesagt, das löst mein Problem, behalte Matthias Ettrich stand damals, es löst mein Problem. Und es gibt einfach nichts Besseres. Also das kann man in seinem Announcement auch lesen. Das ist ein Standpunkt, den kann man vertreten. Dafür ist er auch sehr geflamed worden. Also es ist einer der längsten Flamebores, die ich je gelesen habe, weil diese KDE-Entwicklung. Aber man muss halt... Ich bin jetzt natürlich ziemlich beierst, wenn ich sage, es ist ein verdammt gutes Toolkit oder eins der besten, den ich kenne. Und ich muss zugeben, ich habe andere auch ausprobiert. Muss dazu sagen, es ist schon sehr gut. Natürlich kenne ich die damalige Situation nicht, aber es kann eigentlich nicht viel besser gewesen sein.
Was hat sich denn jetzt bei der Version 4 von Qt dann verbessert? Also ich kenne ein paar Programme, die mit Qt entwickelt sind, die ja zum Beispiel auch auf dem Backentusch laufen. Bekanntes Beispiel, das nehme ich an, ist Google Earth. Da muss ich sagen, da bin ich mit dem User Interface nicht sehr glücklich. Das ist clumsy. Was verspricht denn da jetzt, die neue Version vielleicht anders zu machen?
Das User Interface ist ja immer eine Frage, wie nutzt du die Sachen von Qt? Also Google hat halt den Fehler gemacht, es hat sehr viele Sachen statisch eingelinkt. Und sobald du das tust und dann nicht aufs OS, Qt nicht die Möglichkeit gibst, auf jeweilige OS einzugehen, in dem Moment hast du natürlich das Problem, dass das natürlich auch aussieht wie das, worunter die Leute entwickelt haben. Und wenn du dir Google Earth anguckst, dann siehst du, dass das Windows war. Qt4 ist halt modularer. Also Qt3 war im Prinzip eine oder maximal zwei große Libraries. Das ist halt aufgeteilt worden, sodass halt wirklich nur noch das in dein Programm reinlegen muss, was du wirklich brauchst. Das ist halt auch einer der Gründe, was KDE4 kleinmacht, gerade wenn du nicht alle KDE4-Programme lädst. Und es sind halt viele Sachen neu geschrieben worden. Du hast zum Beispiel eine komplett neue Grafik-Engine. Du hast verbessertes Multithreading, was jetzt mit den ganzen Dual-, Triple-Quad-Tasse nicht gesehen Core-CPUs jetzt auch für Normal-User wichtig wird. Und dann halt noch weitere High-Level-Abstraktionen, die Multithreading nutzen. Jetzt ganz aktuell eine KDE-Entwicklung übrigens auch, Phonon. Das heißt, früher hatte es immer das Problem, unter Unix war es eh immer Mau mit Support und Windows.
Also Support von was?
Von Sound und Video. Also Multimedia. Genau. Das heißt, du hast letztendlich irgendwas doch neu geschrieben, obwohl du Qt hattest. Das war natürlich sehr unbefriedigend, weil das so eine Sache ist, die du sehr häufig brauchst.
Ist Phonon jetzt ein Feature von KDE oder ist es ein Feature von Qt?
Das ist das erste Mal, dass es anders rumgelaufen ist. Normalerweise basiert KDE immer auf Qt-Features. Erweitert die Libraries manchmal, und diesmal war es so, dass es innerhalb des KDE-Projekts entwickelt wurde. Und Trolltech hat gesagt, das ist so gut, das hätten wir gerne auch in Qt drin, hat sich dann mit den Entwicklern geeinigt. Und im Gegensatz zu dem Rest von Qt ist es halt LGPL. Das heißt, jeder darf es benutzen. Und Trolltech hat gesagt, wisst ihr was, ihr habt ja schon eine Xeam-Engine und eine G-Streamer-Engine. Und wir spendieren euch dazu, damit wir es brauchen können, die QuickTime und die Active Directory DirectX-Implementierung.
Das heißt, um das mal kurz zu abstrahieren, Phonon ist ein Framework, das sich sozusagen über oder davor ein existierendes Multimedia-Subsystem legt und eine abstrahierte Oberfläche, ein einheitliches Benutzerinterface für Programmierer schafft. So dass man das benutzen kann und im Hintergrund benutzt man Subsysteme wie QuickTime dann auf Mac.
Genau.
Wie heißt das nochmal gleich auf Windows?
Nee, manchmal DirectX.
Das ist das, was da drangepackt wird. Beziehungsweise, was sagtest du jetzt Xenon unter Linux?
Xenon oder G-Streamer. Kannst du dir halt auch suchen.
Kann man denn das garantieren, dass sich das dann wirklich einheitlich verhält und auch wirklich die notwendigen Abstraktionen, die das Subsystem bereitstellt, dann auch wirklich rüberbringt?
Na, du musst halt überlegen, was brauchst du? Normalerweise, die meisten Programme wollen einfach nur Sound abspielen. Dann kommen ein paar dazu, die wollen ein bisschen mehr, die wollen ein bisschen filtern können. Also ein paar Filter anwenden und so weiter. Das alles geht. Also wir haben, es gibt die Aussage der Entwickler, die halt sagen, wir gehen davon aus, dass sie 90% der Use Cases abdecken lassen. Und wenn du jetzt wirklich speziell in die Audioverarbeitung gehst, dann wirst du dir eh irgendwie den Stack Hand auslesen. Dann wirst du dich nicht auf das verlassen wollen, was da drunter wirklich abgeht. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall mal eine Verbesserung zuvor. Da hat es nämlich genau Arts, das halt so seine Probleme hatte, Stichwort Latenz, Overhead. Und zum Schluss ist dann auch der Maintainer-Hops gegangen. Und es war einfach derartig komplex, dass er an jemanden mehr durchgestiegen ist. Also sollte er halt auch irgendwie über Netzwerke Sound und Video schicken können. Also so ein bisschen dieser X-Server-Ansatz, das war halt einfach viel zu viel für das, was es eigentlich tun sollte. Und es ging auch eigentlich so ein bisschen andershervor vorbei.
Von daher ist es eigentlich ein relativ minimalistischer Ansatz. Also man versucht relativ wenig erst mal abzudecken, weil ja eigentlich das meiste durch die Subsysteme abgedeckt wird. Aber dadurch hatten wir natürlich immer noch das Problem, dass so Plugins, die jetzt in dieses Innenleben hineingehen wollen, was weiß ich, Codex, die man installiert, oder Audiofilter, Videofilter, würde mir jetzt als erstes einfallen, dass die nach wie vor subsystemspezifisch sind und so durch Phono nicht adressiert werden.
Das ist so richtig. Du kannst versuchen, die über... Ich glaube, es gibt mittlerweile auch eine API, wo du Filter reinhängen kannst, wenn du es unbedingt brauchst. Aber ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz sicher, da bin ich auch nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Gut, auf jeden Fall wird versucht, die Situation jetzt für Audio und Video auch unter Ninox zu verbessern. Was du vorhin erwähnt hast, ist dieses Open Sync. Syncing ist ja in zunehmendem Maße ein wichtiges Feature. Ich finde es eine der wichtigsten Sachen für Produktivität. Wenn man mit seinem Rechner arbeitet und wenn man seinen richtigen Personal Computer hat, hat man all diese kleinen Devices, die alle auch irgendwie mal ein Häppchen abhaben wollen und die vielleicht in der Umstellung dazu beitragen, dass man neue Sachen reinkriegt, so Kalendereinträge auf mobilen Geräten und so. Das ist das, was durch diese OpenSync-Subsystem übernommen wird?
Genau, also das ist eine Sache.
Kann man damit auch ein iPod suchen?
Warte, warte, warte, warte. Also da muss ich jetzt erst mal ganz kurz eine Gleichheit sagen. Also dieses PIM-Modul, was ich halt betreue, das ist halt eine Sache, die ist von der KDE, die ist in KDE4 erst mal ausgeklammert. Da kannst du also weiterhin die KDE3-Sachen nutzen. Das ist dann mit 4.1 erst wieder dabei, einfach weil wir da noch auf das Akunadi-Framework umstellen. Das bedeutet, wir haben ein System, das dir im Hintergrund alle möglichen PIM-Daten und auch Dienste zur Verfügung stellt. Also das Syncing könnte eben auch eine Funktionalität sein. Und alle Programme können darauf zugreifen. Bisher hattest du ja nur Contact und es gab so auch eine Library, aber gegen die musst du dann explizit arbeiten. Und so kannst du halt über Systemdienste wie Debuss beispielsweise unabhängig davon, ob du ein KDE-Programm bist oder sonst irgendwas auf diesen Store zugreifen, der eben Akunadi ist und der dir wie gesagt zum Beispiel auch mit der Desktop-Suche zusammenarbeiten kann. Es ist alles das, was du an Dienstleistungen als Programmierer-Dienstleistungen erwartest in Bezug auf Mails, Kalender, Arbeitsumgebung mit zum Beispiel Syncing oder so etwas.
V-Cards.
V-Cards, genau. Das kann sie speichern, das spricht Protokolle, also IMAP, POP, was auch immer. Und speichert die Sachen für dich, wie gesagt, und du kannst halt darauf zugreifen und gewisse Dienste anfragen.
Und ist da jetzt auch Syncing von Geräten drin?
Das wird es dann wahrscheinlich über Open Sync machen, aber im Moment geht es halt vor allen Dingen darum, erst mal diese klassischen PIM-Dienste, also das, was Kontakt jetzt abdeckt, zu machen. Und Open Sync ist ja erst mal ein eigenes Programm. Das könnte man zum Beispiel später dann über, beispielsweise, Demos abdecken.
Okay, wie sieht das jetzt aus so mit Geräten? Also, so eine der Killer-Features derzeit jetzt von modernen Betriebssystemen ist ja, ich kaufe mir eine Kamera bei einem Sartorn.
Genau.
Dann schließe ich die an und dann sagt die, hallo, ich bin Kamera, was willst du denn machen mit den Bildern, den Filmchen?
Also, in Bezug auf Kameras, das decken die Programme schon ganz gut ab. Wo es wirklich problematisch wird, ist hier, wir haben ja gerade unsere Handys vor uns liegen, die einzelnen Protokolle zu implementieren. Ich habe es jetzt gerade mit meinem Handy probiert, während der Kollege mit iSync mal eben Leisure abgezogen ist, hatte ich damit auch mal einen recht großen Mühen. Da ist auf jeden Fall noch viel zu tun. Nur das Problem ist, wir können auf dem Desktop so viel machen, wie wir wollen. Wenn die darunter liegende Implementierung das nicht hergibt, sieht es mau aus. Da müssen auch die Hersteller kooperieren.
Aber das tun sie noch nicht unbedingt.
Scheinen sie nicht immer zu tun. Man sollte ja gerade immer meinen, so SyncML oder so, das ist Standard, toll. Aber unterm Strich gibt es dann wieder so viele Sachen. Und bei Nokia muss dann genau das da drin stehen, sonst sagt es dir nö. Und bei Sony Ericsson das. Das ist schon seltsam.
Nervig bestimmt auch.
Ja, es ist natürlich auch frustrierend, wenn man denkt, jetzt hat man Standards, die ja dann auch wirklich gewollt sind von irgendwelchen Industrie-Konsortien. Und es funktioniert einfach immer noch nicht.
Ja, gibt es noch irgendwelche nennenswerten Feature-Erleichterungen für normale Anwender? Ich glaube, du hast erwähnt, dass eine Rechtschreibkorrektur jetzt auch Einzug gefunden hat.
Genau, also Rechtschreibkorrektur hatten wir schon immer. Was da jetzt neu ist, du hast ja recht häufig, dass du irgendwie mal zum Beispiel Sprachen mischt. Also du schreibst irgendwie einen Teil auf Deutsch und dann ist da noch ein englischer Teil drin.
Wenn es nur ein Zitat ist, ja.
Genau, wenn es nur ein Zitat ist. Und dann hast du direkt WUM-Rot, weil es natürlich, passt natürlich nicht. Und der ist halt clever genug, über Heuristiken rauszufinden, okay, der Teil ist Englisch, der Teil ist Deutsch, der Teil ist Farsi, weiß ja gar ja was. Und versucht das dann entsprechend in der jeweiligen Sprache mit dem Spellchecker zu korrigieren, also im Kontext. Das ist natürlich auch schon mal extrem viel wert.
Fein. Jetzt, so unter der Haube, gibt es ja auch noch eine andere Entwicklung, du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, am Anfang, deine erste Kontribution war Khtml. Das ist ja so ein Subsystem von KDE, was über Umwege jetzt zu großem Ruhm gelangt ist. Apple hat sich irgendwann dieser Rendering-Engine angenommen, sie überarbeitet und unter einem neuen Namen veröffentlicht, bekannt als WebKit, was ja ein Renderer ist, der großen Erfolg hat gerade, wenn man sich anschaut, auf welchen Plattformen der überall gemacht wird. Natürlich auf dem Mac und dem iPhone und so weiter, aber Symbian verwendet einen WebKit-basierten Browser. Das OpenMoco-Projekt setzt auf WebKit. Auch unter Gnome gibt es jetzt, glaube ich, schon einen WebKit-Browser. Und bei KDE ist es jetzt auch so weit gekommen, dass man auf WebKit umschwenkt. Finde ich das richtig?
Also jetzt in 4.0 haben wir noch ein einfach ein erweitertes KTML drauf, was daran liegt, dass Treutech gesagt hat, wir brauchen WebKit. Das ist eben noch eine Sache, die wir danach schieben können. Das nächste Qt4.4 wird in WebKit-Komponenten drin haben. Und dann fangen wir natürlich nicht an, das selber zu machen, sondern wir übernehmen das dann an der Stelle, sodass du im Prinzip sobald KDE41 rauskommt, dann WebKit nehmen kannst. Das Problem ist halt, dass Apple sich nicht, gerade bei der KDE-Community nicht gerade beliebt gemacht hat, indem es irgendwie zwei Jahre im Stellenkämmerlein werkelt und dann sagt, übrigens, ihr habt da zwei Jahre gearbeitet. Wir übrigens auch. Und wir haben jetzt was komplett anderes da stehen, auf derselben Code-Basis. Hier ist der Dump, hier ist der Tarball. Viel Spaß beim Diff-Suchen. Und das hat dann sehr viele Leute doch ziemlich vor den Kopf gestoßen. Man muss allerdings sagen, dass sie es natürlich auch geschafft haben, mit bemerkenswerten Community-Building halt wirklich Firmen und auch freie Projekte, um WebKit zu scharren. Und es ist technologisch mittlerweile einfach das Projekt, das da weiter ist und das auch wahrscheinlich die meiste Manpower erfährt. Und wir müssen uns halt, und das ist wohl auch im Moment auf dem besten Wege gerade, dadurch, dass Trolltech sich da reingehängt hat, irgendwie eine Basis finden, sodass wir sagen können, wir arbeiten da drauf. Und Apple kann nicht sagen, wir machen den Shop morgen zu. Und dann könnt ihr sehen, wie eure Entwicklungsplattform ohne uns weiter läuft. Ich meine, die Code können sie uns nicht nehmen, aber halt die ganze Infrastruktur macht ja schon mal genug kaputt, wenn die auf einmal weg ist. Und wenn das läuft, dann spricht da wahrscheinlich auch nichts dagegen, dass wir umschwenken. Und da ist schon viel Arbeit geleistet worden, also auch Überzeugungsarbeit. Das ist weniger eine technische Sache als wirklich eine...
Politische Community-Frage.
Genau, man muss mit einer Community auch arbeiten können. Und das muss Apple einfach beweisen.
Ja, also mit keinem Projekt... Also wir haben ja verschiedene Sachen auch unter Open Source geleast, also jetzt nicht nur ihren Kernel. Da arbeitet eigentlich fast niemand mit dran. Es gibt so diverse Programme, die auch Open Source veröffentlicht wurden. Die haben aber dann in der Regel selten... Also man kann die dann zwar nehmen und irgendwie versuchen zu portieren oder so. Das ist ja alles ganz schön. Aber bei WebKit sieht man ja ganz deutlich, dass dort wirklich auch der Versuch unternommen wird, Community-Beteiligung zu bekommen.
Also gerade nachdem sie halt gemerkt haben, wie viele Leute diesem Projekt skeptisch gegenüber standen. Du hast gerade den Colonel angesprochen, wo es ja dann auch so auf und ab gab. Von wegen wird es jetzt einen Colonel für geben, ja, nein. Für die nächste Release, wo bleibt der Source dafür? Dann ist ja das Darwin. Da musst du mich jetzt korrigieren, wenn das Open Darwin ist. Zumindest als Webseite eingestellt.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen gestorben. Weil das liegt einfach daran, dass da einfach niemand dran mitarbeiten wollte. Woran das hier rumliegt, vermag ich so recht nicht zu sagen.
Den wirklichen Bruch gab es ja dann, als man ihn gehadert hat. Als sie auf Intel gegangen sind, wird man das jetzt weiterhin veröffentlichen oder wollen die verhindern, dass man jetzt... Aber es hat sich ja Gott sei Dank hauptsächlich als Paranoia herausgestellt.
Also Apple hat einfach, nachdem sie die Rechner rausgebracht haben, wohl noch zu arbeiten gehabt, bevor sie dieses Release rausbringen. Das ist so die eine Sichtweise. Andere sagen, naja, sie wollten sich erstmal security-technisch sicher sein, dass sie nicht irgendwas ganz Schlimmes gebracht haben. Weil natürlich der Wechsel auf Intel automatisch die internationale Security-Szene, die sich bestens auf der Plattform auskennt, einlädt, drauf rumzuhauen. Was weiß ich, letztlich ist es so, dass das, was sie von Anfang an gemacht haben, nach dem ersten Release jetzt auch durchgezogen haben und man kriegt nach wie vor für jedes Dot-Release den vollständigen Source Code, mit der Ausnahme der paar Sachen, die sie halt nicht veröffentlichen können, halt die übliche Geschichte mit Grafikkartentreibern und so weiter, wo dann eben die Herstellerfirmen den Daumen drauf haben, was ja auch der Linux-Szene immer wieder Probleme bereitet, oder WLAN-Treiber und solche Sachen.
Genau, das ist aber ganz interessant, wo du gerade sagst, Grafiktreiber. Da gibt es halt auch eine interessante Entwicklung. Viele Leute trampeln ja immer teilweise zu Recht, teilweise nicht, auf dem Xorg-Server rum. Und da gibt es eine ganz interessante Entwicklung, nun so am Rande von der Firma, die jetzt auch die Treiber für Intel beispielsweise schreibt, die da sehr stark schon immer sind. Ich habe mir das Name gerade entfallen. Das ist ein Framework, Galium 3D, mit dem du im Prinzip die gratite 3D-Beschleunigung und das Entwickeln von neuen X-Server-Treibern enorm vereinfachen kannst. Das muss wohl echt Pan in the Air sein im Moment. Und ja, hoffen wir, dass es dann auch für die 3D-Effekte weitergeht. Ich habe zum Beispiel für KDE ein paar 3D-Effekte gebaut. Also du siehst ja, was es auf Mac tun kann. Und musst du dann aber einfach feststellen, dass wenn du die außerhalb von einem Fullscreen benutzt, die meisten X-Server, ich habe halt einen Intel, da lief es ganz gut. Und dann habe ich es mir immer auf dem Arty angeguckt. Und das war dann halt nicht mehr so lustig. Also dass wir solche Effekte dann hoffentlich ein bisschen mehr sehen werden in Zukunft auch in KDE. Also es liegt halt, muss man ganz deutlich sagen, nicht immer nur am Desktop Environment, sondern wir müssen uns halt auch an dem orientieren, was wir an Technik zur Verfügung haben, ohne dass die Benutzer zu 50% unglücklich sind.
KDE ist ja nun auch ein System, was sich sehr profiliert, finde ich zumindest, dadurch, dass es eine vergleichsweise große Zahl von Desktop-Anwendungen gibt. Da ist die Situation auf jeden Fall deutlich besser, als es noch vor einigen Jahren war. Ich habe jetzt nicht so einen guten Überblick. Vielleicht kannst du mal sagen, was sich in den letzten zwei Jahren da so getan hat. Welche Anwendungen auf KDE aufsetzen, die erwähnenswert sind?
Also, KONFOR nutzt tatsächlich auch sehr viele Leute, unabhängig von KDE. Dann hast du K3B. Wenn du ein Brennprogramm unter Linux brauchst, das ist eigentlich das Programm, das du haben willst.
PCDs und DVDs zum Brennen.
Genau. Du hast für das Pin-Management Kontakt relativ viele Sachen, die du gerade im Pin-Bereich nicht wissen möchtest.
Ich meine jetzt auch ein bisschen weniger die Tools, die jetzt als integraler Bestandteil von KDE angesehen werden können, die quasi mit der Standardinstallation dabei sind, sondern so Third-Party in Einführungsstrichen, die jetzt auch neue Anwendungsmöglichkeiten öffnen. Also ich weiß, es gibt zum Beispiel dieses, wie heißt das, Carp Paint Programm, nein nicht Carp Paint, was?
Krita meinst du?
Ja genau, was?
Na, das ist halt wieder die Frage, was du als integraler Bestandteil siehst. Du kannst sagen, wir haben nur dieses KDE Base, also das, was du unbedingt haben musst, also KDE Lips und Base, aber wir haben zum Beispiel die ganzen EDU-Programme oder auch das K-Office, was wir mittlerweile separat releasen, was aber auch so eine K-Office, unsere Office Suite, die wir halt separat releasen. Krita ist jetzt in dem Office drin. Du kannst es natürlich, weil die Distributoren das immer auch so kleinen Atomara paketieren, als einzelnes Programm haben. Aber du siehst, das sind halt Pakete und bis auf das K-Office liefern wir die meisten Pakete, die das engere Chorteam bei KDE irgendwie zusammenbaut. Das machen wir halt in Paketen. Und liefern das jeweils pro Release aus. Das heißt zu sagen, das, was jetzt so im Standard-Release drin ist, ist ein bisschen schwierig. Wo wir halt zum Beispiel was haben, was komplett außerhalb läuft, was aber trotzdem so an KDE andockt ist, zum Beispiel Amarok. Amarok ist ja immer noch so eine große Sache. Noch mal kurz zur Erläuterung. Amarok ist Musikplayer, Schrägstrich, Musikorganisator.
Und Podcast-Client.
Und super Podcast-Client, in der Tat.
Ich hab da ja meine... Also ich bin da ja... Also ich wünsche mir da noch einiges. Ich hab's jetzt schon eine Weile lang nicht mehr angeschaut. Das letzte Mal fehlt mir noch einiges. Aber ich führe erst mal aus.
Genau. Und da ist es halt auch so, dass es unter Linux, ja, was gab's da? Es gab XMMS, wer halt so dieses Winamp-Feeling mochte. Und eigentlich noch, glaub ich, sogar Bevor's Eye, oder ungefähr zum gleichen Zeit, wo es halt iTunes gab, gab's halt so, dass so dieses Programme, die halt versucht haben, gleichzeitig immer noch so ein bisschen Musikorganizer zu sein. So nach dem Motto, du hast deine Giga, slash Terabyte, MP3s, OK, oder was auch immer, die du gerne verwalten möchtest. Und du möchtest die aber gleichzeitig noch vernünftig anhören können. Und so dieses Gebiet versucht halt, Amarok so ein bisschen auszufüllen. Und also weniger jetzt so auf eierlegende Wollmichsaal. Du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn nicht mit allem Möglichen erweitern, sondern wirklich mehr so die wesentlichen Sachen, sprich Musik, wo immer sie herkommt. Sie haben sich zum Beispiel, also Amarok, die Entwickler sind halt sehr darauf bedacht, das Ganze nicht ausufern zu lassen.
Aktuelle Version ist 1.4. Weißt du zufällig, wann die so rausgekommen ist?
Ja, die Fast-Forward-Reihe, die gibt es jetzt schon ein Jahr, anderthalb, also schon relativ lange. Es sind halt sehr viele Subreleases rausgekommen, wo halt immer mal wieder Verbesserungen sind. Also wenn Apple mal wieder entschieden hat, wir müssen das Verfahren, ein iPod jetzt mit Musik zu bespielen, verändern für eine neue iPod-Serie, dann wird das halt nachgefixt.
Das ist aber jetzt ein interessanter Punkt. Amarok ist in der Lage, mit dem iPod zu Sünden.
Ja, das ist nicht nur mit dem iPod, also mit recht vielen MP3-Playern oder Musik-Playern.
Aber eben auch mit dem iPod.
Eben auch mit dem iPod.
Also das ist von daher auch mal eine wirkliche Alternative zu iTunes an der Stelle.
Und da wird es eben auch interessant, dass solche Sachen wie Amarok eben jetzt auch unter Mac OS und Windows laufen sollen. Durch QT4. Dadurch, dass QT4 eben sowohl lizenzmäßig, als auch technisch es uns jetzt sehr viel einfacher macht, zu portieren. Und KDE auch gesagt hat, wir ergreifen diese Gelegenheit am Schopfe und machen die KDE-Libs eben auch portierbar. Das heißt, der Teil, der Linux spezifisch ist, der wird ausgesondert. Und wir versuchen einfach das, was wir ohne Spezifiker hinkriegen, auch dann auf die anderen Systeme zu portieren.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt als Anwendungsentwickler auf KDE 4 aufsetze, dann habe ich die Möglichkeit, und da können sicherlich noch sehr viele andere Aspekte als jetzt nur die GUI-Integration mit dazu. Man kann ja auch ansonsten leicht Betriebssystem abhängig programmieren, aber man hat zumindest schon mal eine gute Voraussetzung, um seine Software dann auch so zu übersetzen, dass sie auf dem Mac läuft.
Genau. Also wir haben jetzt auch das System umgestellt, mit dem du als Softwareentwickler deine Software kompilierst. Also wer Entwickler ist, kennt wahrscheinlich Automake und Autoconf und Auto-Autsch.
Auto-Autsch?
Ja, ach, das ist diese Auto-Tools, die sind halt...
Auto-Auawe.
Ja, genau.
Jaja, das ist wirklich sehr modern.
Jedenfalls werden wir jetzt umgestellt auf ein System namens CMake. Es gab dann den großen Kampf der Bildsysteme, als es dann hieß, Autoconf tut halt gar nicht. Also Anlass waren halt so Sachen wie Paralleles bauen, was wir gerade bei KDE mitnehmen.
Ja, Autoconf ist ja auch wirklich wie alt, 20 Jahre. Also das ging einfach gar nicht mehr.
Und auf M4, wer kann M4? Also kennst du jemanden, der M4 kennt?
Also für die Leute, die jetzt überhaupt nicht wissen, wovon wir reden, Automech, Autoconf, das ist halt so aus den frühen Zeiten, als es noch hunderte Unix-Versionen gab und Unix-Software versucht hat, auf allen zu übersetzen, was immer ein großer Schmerz war, da waren das einfach hilfreiche Skripte, die einmal so komplett durch den Source Code durchgebügelt sind und versucht haben, rauszukriegen, wie man das jetzt am besten übersetzen kann, beziehungsweise das Betriebssystem analysiert haben und geschaut haben, wo bin ich denn jetzt hier eigentlich, um dann den Source Code entsprechend anzupassen. Aber das ist natürlich ein Moloch und schwer zu handhaben. Also jetzt CMake als modernere Variante von Make.
Genau, mit Zwischenschritt Scons, also das war so eine Python-basierte Geschichte. Wie gesagt, es gab ja diesen großen Wettbewerb und es hat sich aber CMake durchgesetzt. Was halt daran lag, dass gerade die CMake-Macher zu allen gesagt haben, CMake ist gedacht als Plattform, unabhängige Bildlösung, was ja auch bei Autoconf und Automake teilweise problematisch ist. Und dass sie gesagt haben, wenn ihr ein Problem habt, kommt zu uns, wir bauen das ein, was dann so weit ging, dass derjenige, der das bei KDE portiert hat, schlussendlich bei dieser Firma angefangen hat, zumindest für eine gewisse Zeit zu arbeiten. Also die waren da sehr entgegenkommt.
Ja, das heißt, hast du noch weitere Beispiele außer Amarok, die jetzt so als Anwendung, also die Frage ist ja eigentlich so, wie attraktiv ist KDE jetzt wirklich für Anwendungsentwicklung? Oder ist die Szene nach wie vor gezwungen, quasi aus eigenem Antrieb heraus was zu machen? Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal kurz das Car Office beleuchten. Ich finde es insofern ganz interessant, als dass das ja neben dem Microsoft Office, was nach wie vor alles dominiert, Apple hat ja mittlerweile auch da seine eigenen Schritte unternommen, mit iWork eine Alternative anzubieten. Dann gibt es natürlich vor allem in der Open Source-Software-Szene, freien Software-Szene Open Office, was eine alte Entwicklung auch aus Deutschland war interessanterweise, ja dann mal von Sun gekauft wurde, jetzt komplett frei ist. Was für eine Rolle spielt K Office? Was versucht K Office da anders zu machen oder genauso zu machen? Geht es da wirklich darum, kompatibel zu sein? Oder ist es einfach so klein und fein?
Ja, also klein und fein ist natürlich eine wichtige Sache, die man Open Office voraus hat und was man im Moment so als den Faktor sieht. Und das andere ist natürlich, es ist eine komplette ODF-Implementierung, eine zweite. Das heißt? Open Document Format.
Das heißt, es benutzt dasselbe Dateiformat wie Open Office.
Richtig. Und eben auch eins, das iso-normiert ist, wovor man sich natürlich auch erhofft, dass das ein bisschen interoperabler, dann ein bisschen in Zerpabilität gestalten wird.
Das sogenannte Oasis Open Document Format.
Richtig. Richtig, genau. Also wenn du dir das halt anguckst. Und in KDE4, in KAUFIS 2.0, was ja dann eben auch auf KDE4 basieren wird, hat man sich halt ganz klar zum Ziel genommen, Open Office noch weiter auszubauen, das auch zu professionalisieren. Das hat sich jetzt also eine Firma gegründet, die aus den wichtigsten Entwicklern besteht, die halt auch kommerziellen Support bieten wollte. Also so ein bisschen hat man ja immer gesagt, Open Office ist ja so ganz nett, aber wenn es dann professionell werden soll, dann nimmt man halt doch lieber Open Office. Und zum anderen mehren sich dann aber auch so die Stimmen, die gesagt haben, ja, Open Office ist ja auch ganz nett, aber es ist halt ein Moloch. Und da haben die KDE-Entwickler halt gesagt, okay, dann versuchen wir doch eine Alternative darzustellen. Und aus dem KDE Office, was in KDE 3 halt viele Sachen noch hatte, wo man sich als professioneller Anwärter drüber geärgert hat, also Stichwort, so Frontdarstellung und so, jetzt endgültig in den Griff zu kriegen. Und wo übrigens auch QT4 sehr beigeholfen hat. Und ja, da eine Alternative an den Start zu bringen.
Also K-Office ist ja eine sehr umfangreiche Office-Lösung. Also da geht es jetzt nicht nur so um den Kern von Text und Präsentation und Tabellenkalkulation, sondern es gibt auch Formula-Editor, Chart-Tool, eben das Krita, was wir schon erwähnt haben, also die Grafik-Anwendung. Was sehe ich hier noch? Ein Diagrammtool und auch so eine Desktop-Datenbank, was ich ja ganz interessant finde, das Keksi. Ich bin ja so ein alter Filemaker-User, schon sehr früh mit Filemaker gearbeitet, da hat mich immer gewundert, warum eigentlich dieses Konzept nicht um sich greift, weil eigentlich alle Leute immer wieder so das Bedürfnis haben, mal eben eine kleine Datenbank zu pflegen, ohne jetzt gleich einen SQL Server aufsetzen zu wollen, der dann auch recht komplex in der Maintenance ist und auch im Aufsetzen. Was gibt es da noch für erwähnenswerte Komponenten? Kivio sehe ich hier gerade noch. Das war dieses Diagrammtool.
Genau, Visio. Krita hast du eben schon angesprochen. Man vergleicht es immer so ein bisschen mit GIMP. Es geht aber weniger in Richtung Photoshop, als zu dem, was Corel damals hatte. Weißt du noch den Namen?
Nein, weiß ich nicht. Ich kenne nur Corel Drawer.
Krita geht auch in Richtung Bildmanipulation, Filter zu haben. Du kannst also mit 16 Bit pro Kanal arbeiten. Es geht an einige Stellen schon in den professionellen Bereich rein. Sogar ein bisschen weiter als GIMP. Und es ist verfolgt auch ein paar andere Ansätze. Ich bin mir jetzt echt nicht mehr sicher.
Das ist ja auf jeden Fall erwähnt in dem Zusammenhang. Wie auch immer. Also, K-Office, tolle Sache. Ist sehr umfangreich. Ich bewundere den Mut der KDE-Szene für alles, wo es offensichtlich einen Bedarf gibt, mit einer richtigen Anwendung ranzugehen. Und sich dann auch immer wieder einen neuen Namen auszudenken, der mit K anfängt.
Da sind wir jetzt schon weggegangen in KDE4.
Mit Amarok, aber das ist das K am Ende.
Amarok ist ja auch schon ein paar Tage älter als KDE4.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert, so Dolphin und so weiter. Sind euch jetzt die Worte ausgegangen?
Nein, es ist sogar so, dass wir die Release-Namen absichtlich Worte genommen haben, wo sogar im Englischen ein K gestanden hätte und dann C davor geschrieben. Jetzt verfalle ich mich doch nicht mehr so.
Das liegt dir jetzt einfach mal so.
Nein, das liegt mir nicht auf der Zunge. Codenamen kennt man doch, das ist doch cool. Codenamen kennt man doch, das ist cool. Ja, das war natürlich...
Warum, weil das so in Deutsch klingt?
Zum einen, weil das Leute... Also am Anfang war es ja immer so ein bisschen necken, so von wegen, ja, K, haha, sehr lustig. Also wenn du auf slash.de die Announcements zu KDE eh mal siehst, war dann immer der obligatorische Post, wo jemand einen Satz gestrickt hat, wo alles mit K begonnen hat. Es ist dann... Aber es gab dann auch wirklich Leute, die gesagt haben, es klingt in unserer Sprache unangenehm. Und man muss ja auch nicht wirklich alles immer mit K machen. Zumal es halt einfach irgendwie auch catchiger klingt, teilweise, wenn du eben zu Worten gehst, die nicht total gekünstelt klingen. Wobei ich auch sagen muss, dass mir nicht alle Einnahmen gefallen, auch wenn ein natürlich irgendwie weicher klingt.
Oder alle G-Namen.
Oder alle G-Namen oder alle X-Namen, wie auch immer. Das ist halt die Frage, nennst du es wirklich funktional?
Oder WinFu.
Oder Mac. Da kann man sich sicherlich nicht drüber streiten, aber guck dir halt Plasma an oder irgendwie solche Sachen, die halt irgendwie eine gewisse Einstellung zu der Sache beschreiben und nicht jetzt das Produkt konkret oder irgendwelche Zugehörigkeiten zu irgendwelchen Projekten.
Wie geht es weiter mit KDE? Und vor allem, was ich euch auch nochmal ansprechen sollte, was für Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten gibt es denn noch für Open-Source-Entwickler bei KDE einzusteigen? Wonach sucht ihr? Was sind so die Opportunities? Habt ihr coole Partys?
Ja, das wirst du heute Abend sehen. Da darfst du gerne nochmal ein Addon zum Podcast machen oder so.
Oder den Live-Bericht.
Das ist natürlich zur Party. Generell, wir werden auf jeden Fall noch viel machen auf dieser KDE4-Basis. Wir betrachten KDE4 als die Plattform und 4.0 ist jetzt das Release. Also gerade hier, wenn wir von Plasma sprechen, wie gesagt Panel, Desktop und so weiter, hast du heute schon ganz coole Möglichkeiten, irgendwie da Widgets anzuordnen, wie du das unter Supercaramba oder jetzt auch mit Mac OS irgendwann eingeführt wurde oder jetzt unter Windows. Das ist alles ganz nett. Es ist aber noch sehr rudimentär. Wir möchten dieser Technologie noch einiges verbessern. Das heißt, wenn es Leute gibt, die sagen, wir haben da coole Ideen, wir möchten uns gerne ein bisschen ausweiten, dann natürlich, es gibt nach wie vor viel zu portieren. Im PIM-Bereich suchen wir heute, ich habe das gerade schon am Anfang der Sendung angesprochen. Wir möchten das gerne auf Akunadi basieren und wirklich den Desktop PIM-basiert machen. PIMM, genau, PIMM. PIMM my Desktop, genau. Nettes Stichwort eigentlich dafür für so eine Aktion. Genau, sodass du also deine Daten, deine E-Mails total selbstverständlich aus jedem Programm raus, aus dem Kontext im Prinzip nutzen kannst. Also das ist eigentlich eine Sache, die habe ich eigentlich in keinem Betriebssystem wirklich gesehen, dass sie das wirklich so zur Verfügung stellt. Und da ist halt noch eine Menge Potenziale.
Wird es denn noch lange dauern bis KDE 4.1?
Oder ist jetzt das Endes nur ein kleiner Schritt? Nee, also wir sind jetzt wieder dabei, das ganze time-based zu machen. Nachdem wir 4.0 natürlich schon ein bisschen feature-based machen mussten, weil wir können nicht einfach einen halben Fertigstest haben, weil wir mit Releasen...
Das heißt, jetzt gibt es sozusagen einen Release-Zeitpunkt, den man anstrebt, und dann haut man das raus, und bis du es eigentlich geschafft hast, ist halt nicht...
Genau, die Idee ist jetzt ein halbes Jahr.
Aber diese Webkit-Geschichte wird es auf jeden Fall schaffen?
Die wird es schaffen ganz alleine, weil die ja eine relativ reine QT-Sache ist, und was wir machen, müssen wir schreiben. Wir nehmen diese Bibliothek, schreiben da so ein Kapat drum, habe ich ja auch am Anfang erzählt. So eine Komponente, packen das in den Conqueror rein und...
Fertig ist. Und das ist aber auch schon fertig sozusagen. Also QT hat das schon. Das 4.1 ist ja schon draußen, oder?
Nein, QT. Warte mal, vorsichtig. QT ist 4.4. QT ist 4.4, genau. Das ist noch nicht released? Nee, das ist noch nicht released. Das kommt jetzt aber auch im Q1. Also das ist jetzt, innerhalb der nächsten Monate, müsst du das rauskriegen.
Angeblich. Okay, gut. Aber das wird es wahrscheinlich schaffen.
Genau.
Okay. Ja, super. Ich denke, das war jetzt mal ein schöner, geschmeidiger. Hast du noch einen Nachwurf?
Ja, und zwar, du hast gerade gesagt, Leute, die Interesse haben. Dafür haben wir jetzt einen extra Anlaufpunkt. Ich weiß, dass du ein sehr großer Wiki-Freund bist. Das haben die Leute mal geflüstert. Genau. Und wir haben auch gesagt, Beteiligen ist für Entwickler sicherlich in Wikiform das Beste. Das heißt, wir haben alle unsere Doku für Entwickler und für Systemadministratoren in ein Wiki gepackt. Wir nennen das Ganze techbase.kde.org. Da kann ich ein bisschen Werbung für machen, weil ich mache ein bisschen Infrastruktur im Moment. Das gehört auch zu meinen Projekten dazu. Und da ist jeder eingeladen, sich die Dokus durchzulesen. Wir werden jetzt die nächste Initiative starten, da genau um solche Leute dort abzuholen, die sagen, ich möchte in KDE4 was machen. A, wie funktioniert die Technologie genau, ohne dass ich mir jetzt in den Softscope wühlen muss? Und B, wo sind die wunden Punkte, wo man noch viel tun kann? Oder wo gibt es cooles Zeug, das ich jetzt noch machen kann, wenn ich diese und jene Befähigung, Begabung, Interesse habe? Und da lohnt es sich auf jeden Fall nachzuschauen oder entsprechende Seiten halt mal sich zu abonnieren und sich informieren zu lassen, wenn es da Updates gibt. Ansonsten, IRC KDE OK, das Freenote Network, mal auf hashkddevel melden und sagen, hey Leute.
Freenote ist ja sowieso der Entwickler-Tummelplatz.
Genau.
Generell. Und so kann man sich einbringen. Daniel, vielen Dank für die Ausführung zu KDE4. Wir sind alle gespannt. Ich bin vor allem gespannt, bis der Amarok hier auf meinen Mac kommt. Dann werde ich den mal schön auseinandernehmen. Und ich würde mir den sehr genau anschauen. Ich hätte wirklich mal große Lust auf eine Alternative zur iTunes, um ehrlich zu sein, was Podcasting und Sync und so weiter betrifft. Was aber nicht einfach sein wird. Wie auch immer, das war Chaosradio Express. Wieder einmal die Nummer 68. Es ging um KDE4. Und ja, das war es wie immer. Zum Schluss noch der Hinweis, auch wir wollen Feedback haben. chaosradio.ccc.de oder blogchaosradio.ccc.de, die Kommentare in den Post zur Sendung. Ist immer alles gerne gesehen. Verrisse, Belobigungen, alles Vorschläge, Tipps und sonstige Rüffel. Wir rechnen, wir sind mit allen Wassern gewaschen. Schlagt auf uns ein. Super.
Und wenn ihr euch gerne zu technischen Sachen melden wollt, meldet euch bei uns.
Okay, gut, das wars. Bis bald und tschüss.